їх не багатий у алли їх до купи ти
близько 50 та про фестивальний tires про
європейського пульс у Європи де бралася
він середа нести амстердама збер туго то
приходьте вниз він нідерланди нині на
простий people feel dc нідерланди
багато людей відпочивають собі за здавленим
і волосу і на віч його йти кого не про
сема та c проблема європа для диких
політичних партій позбавлятися
адже бувають skype сама така позиція
право тато листя та й найбільші
проблеми вибір його на girl андах порожнього
партії за свободу і до лідера я за
результатом і досвід його не герт вілдерс
аяту я за посилання не контролю на кордоні
то ви його євросоюзу на тому місці
опоненти на поливає членство в ес жити
його важливого для експорту так нову
приватному ринку quite амстердама ще дня
з молотка я дочка близько 30 мільйонів
кліків
теж продавцям ви і дні у відкритті
кордон з ph пішла see
ми спеціалізуємося на Європі з бібі
шива скандинавії швейцарії та італії
наша торгівля закласти у вигляді євросоюзу
там і ще кордону закрити продаватися
буду склад ніші здача подібним труднощам
і ми стикуємо і швейцарії
з європейської околиці там дівоча влада
не провалу там у там ваш до продавати
наші quite well as про економічні
взаємозалежність скепсис нідерландці
автосалону європейського союзу на чому
основним на консультативного референдуму
у дві тисячі п'ятому уроці пари важливо без
6 миша кінці україною видно волосся відра
дефекації конституції з atarax канали не
асоціації євросоюзу з Україною
candlelight макет нідерланди був її
погоджуються Європу і в плані ринку як
місяці для продажу товарів для ручного
транспортування такою мартиною тури або
проте нідерланди ніколи не був
сповнений ентузіазм ще до європейської
політики ланцюжка ну і справа ми
державності національну ідентичність
це суверенітету чому ми нідерланди на
боготу був ще прикладом французик обидва
іспанців і кі так уже давнім це органу
на
7 пальців french ти мені меншими
тональник і справді чув 1
перуку над і вікна епічні по Києву
тому ще побутовим 1 і на нідерланді в
складі з те велике благо